always a love it when Davos 20 calls in
how are you coach I'm good oka doing
well appreciate you having me back oh
come on we've been chatting with you up
for a couple seasons now so I always
enjoy having you on how has things
changed for you now that you have that
championship in your in your case right
now well just you know really really
kind of business as usual for us I mean
it we we were able to win one more game
and obviously it was a big game and I
think the biggest thing is it just you
know having that trophy in the lobby
just kind of validates that you know we
can we can do it that's really it I was
really the only thing we haven't done
around here in the last eight years was
when it all you know but everything
we've done once we've done multiple
times and I think that's a credit to the
commitment of our players and the buy-in
to the culture that we have here and but
as far as you know what we do and really
the reason why we've been so consistent
is is you know we start over every year
regardless of what happens you know we
reinstall the core values and the
philosophy and the vision of the program
as if no one knows it and we kind of
keep that in front as we go through the
new journey and every year that's what
it is it's a new journey new team new
challenges new leadership new roles and
that's the best part about college
football to me is the change that you
have each and every year you know it's
and I obviously would love to have a
Bashan stay here for about 12 years but
but it doesn't work that way so but it's
exciting you know to see new guys step
in and you know every year it's all the
same questions who's going to take this
spot and if you recruit well and you
develop your players well you'll have
someone ready and that's why we've been
so consistent over the past you know
several years
so let's get to it then who is going to
take the spot of deshaun Watson as you
are just a couple of Saturdays removed
from kickoff of the 2017 season
yeah well I'm excited to kind of watch
that play out I mean nobody has to take
the sean's place we just need somebody
to step in and be the the the Clemson
quarterback and the good
we feel like we've recruited well we've
got four young men here that are in camp
right now that we went out and evaluated
and recruited not for them to come be
Deshawn but for them to come in and be
the best version of themselves that's
why we went inside them we think they're
great talents and Kelly Bryant right now
as it would start today that's how we
ended spring and and so far it at this
point in camp we still got a couple
weeks here to go but but so far this
point camp ease he he would start today
but no matter what happens I see us
playing a couple guys you know as we go
through the first part of the season you
know we don't have preseason games you
know in pro football high school
football buddy has preseason games but
we don't so there's still another piece
of the evaluation is like Kelly for
example you know he's done he has been
the most consistent guy in our camp
without question and has has done a
great job but he still got to go do it
in the games you know that's there's
another level you know to the to the
solidification of the job the evaluation
of the job that you know in college
football you only get when you go play
so but I'm really proud of the job
Kelly's done and then we've got Zahra
Cooper and Hunter Johnson
Zarek's our redshirt freshman hunters a
true freshman and both of those young
men I think we could win with either one
of them so chase Brice is another really
promising talent he's not quite ready
yet he just got here this summer
whereas hunter and Jaret were able to go
through spring so the good news is I
really truly believe we've got three
guys that could win for us so it's a
good problem and what I'm looking
forward to you know just continuing the
competition and watch it all play out
would you prefer to have preseason games
we asked this is clay Helton absolutely
you would yes a lovely man I would I
would love to have the opportunity even
if it wasn't at public I would love to
have the opportunity to go and scrimmage
another opponent you know someone that
you you don't know so much about you
know these guys know all they know each
other's nuances and you know when you
when you're on a practice field day in
and day out
plus you know you're not 100% invested
every time we're the head coach every
time that ball gets snapped you're alive
you're 100% invested everybody on
defense everybody on offense your guy so
you know it'd be nice to be able to be
one team on a sideline and be able to go
in and play against another opponent I
think it would be awesome just why the
NFL does it you know they go to practice
they have preseason games because you
know you can only get so much done in
practice we don't really make our
quarterbacks live neither neither does
the NFL and so you know you get into
those games and now sudden there's a
whole nother level of evaluation and
when the when when it's real live
minutes that you're playing and
decisions that are being made so it
would be valuable I would love it
absolutely Clemson head coach Dabo
Swinney joining me here on the show you
know obviously the difference we know
what the difference is between frozen
college then in terms of being able to
have a kid long enough to get them out
there in a preseason game what did you
make of Josh Rosen's comments that
football in school don't go together
it's like trying to do two full-time
jobs
coach well I don't agree with that but
that doesn't mean I'm right you know I
think everybody has a right to their
opinion but I have been a college
athlete and as one who you know what
school Pell grants and student loans so
and then eventually earned a scholarship
so I've kind of experienced you know all
sides of it but I I believe that you
know college football is is incredible
but more importantly education and
sometimes you know people say well
coaches talk about education but but I
can tell you the best stat we got here
and the thing I'm most proud of is I've
had 159 seniors in my program at 154 of
them are graduates and I know the value
of an education and you know for anybody
to say that education is not important I
just think that's irresponsible now if
someone feels like that it's too much to
do both well that's certainly an opinion
and I respect everybody's opinion
you know I think that you know if when
people don't value the college
experience and you know no one has to do
it you don't have to do it but I don't
know it's it's a it's an interesting
topic for sure and who knows what will
happen down the road I don't know if NFL
have a minor league or maybe open it up
where guys don't have to go to college
they can maybe go right into the pros I
have no idea where it's going down the
road but I know this there's incredible
value in a young person or in their
degree and the work ethic the commitment
the sacrifice the discipline that you
have to have to to be a student-athlete
it is it is really really tough but I
know this you know pretty much
everything great in life usually is
tough and so that's just my personal
opinion from experience as having a be a
player and coach for many years and I'm
really proud of the guys who've come
through our program and even last year
you know they were I think there were
only eight hundred and something juniors
that entered the draft and only eight of
them had a college degree before those
eight were from Clemson Mike Williams
Wayne Gulman deshaun Watson and our
Tabas Scott so it's certainly a culture
that we have here that we're proud of
and and our guys buy into that you know
that we they understand the value of
getting their education and we try to
teach them that a you're only gonna play
football for a very very short time and
a few of you will have a chance to play
after after Clemson but even those guys
are you're not going to play long and
you know so we try to make that a real
priority and you know our guys have
bought into that over the last eight
years and I think that's why we've been
you know one of the best in the country
academically a couple more minutes left
with Dabo Swinney of Clemson right here
on the Rich Eisen show let's talk about
some of those players - Sean last time
we spoke you said that anybody didn't
have a first-round grade on deshaun
Watson should be fired
obviously the Houston Texans agree he is
a in a battle with Tom Savage right now
and I have to ask it did you notice that
DeAndre Hopkins said he prefers Savage
coach did you see that the
yeah we saw that and I think I think
DeAndre is a you know he's in camp he's
there and you got a rookie into Sean
Watson that doesn't mean he's not a
first-round Talent but you've got a
veteran guy and you know he's he would
know better than anybody what his
opinion is at that point whenever he
made that statement but you know
everybody in football knows that you got
to earn it every day and you know that's
what I love about Sean is is he's a very
humble young man and you know he'll take
advantage of his opportunity as it comes
and he'll be ready
you know whenever that time is but
there's no question he's a first round
talent that is not even a question
this is this is a guy that that I really
believe is going to proved to be one of
the greats and I can't wait to watch it
all unfold and you know he'll be a great
backup and ready when they need him and
it's when his opportunity comes I don't
have any doubt he'll he'll seize the
moment but you know he's a rookie and
he's got to go in there and iron it and
prove it every day in practice and I
don't have any doubt that he'll earn the
respect of his teammates and the trust
of his coaches and have a great career
hopefully Lord will and keep him healthy
any last couple questions for you any
insight you can give us on Mike Williams
when folks here in Los Angeles might be
able to see him with this bolt on the
side of his helmet oh he's a special
player he really is a great young man
just another guy I'm really proud of a
very humble kid and you know it just he
loves to play and as soon as he can be
out there I know he will he's tough as
they come and just a great competitor
but but this guy has got the body and
the strength and the ball skills and the
athleticism to go with it for such a big
guy that that it's going to be fun to
watch he's going to be a matchup problem
at the next level there's and there's no
doubt and you know I know everybody out
there with the Chargers ranks to get him
on the field and whenever that time
comes he'll make his presence known last
one for you it's being a tough tough
going you've got Kent
date to start then your home for Auburn
then at Louisville right after that and
unnamed ACC coach said Lamar Jackson is
not an NFL quarterback now what do you
say on that subject last word coach I'm
not really worried about what unnamed
people say about Lamar Jackson I'm
worried about the Tigers but all I'm
worried about is how we're going to try
to figure out how to stop them here at
Clemson whether he's an NFL quarterback
or not that's that's for other people to
figure out I'm trying to I'm trying to I
know this he's a he's a great great
college player he's the husband and he
is is a all my knowledge of him a great
young man and I know for a fact he is an
unbelievable competitor so he's a
challenge and know that he's got a
couple more years of college he doesn't
have to be an NFL quarterback today you
know coach Petrino tell you that they're
just trying to get him to be the best
mobile quarterback that he possibly can
be and I promise you he nobody's going
to be excited about paying playing Lamar
Jackson he is a great football player
will be a big challenge for us coach
good luck this season already looking
forward to a chat with you during it
good luck this fall and beyond okay I
appreciate it you got it that's Dabo
Swinney at clemson FB on Twitter so Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country
and audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy